wir wissen
jannis anlagen diesen recyclinghof in
hunzenschwil führt karin bärtschi die
svp grossrätin des kantons aargau
beschäftigt ein gutes dutzend
mitarbeiter auch asylsuchende wir aubel
dieser der eritrea verdankt der svp frau
den einstieg ins schweizer berufsleben
witzig dass auf die menschen
perspektiven haben während viele junge
mann die sind sicher auf 22
doch alle haben zehn hautärzte aber zeit
und ich bin es ganz wichtig dass die
busse sie waren bucht mit macht er bis
in fonds und dass man weiß was sie nach
spanien haben so viel gold könnte jetzt
aber auf unsere linke politikerin co
aber wie spielt sich das achtköpfige
links und rechts an darunter sind
manchmal da sind mit respekt und anstand
begegnet und ich finde es ganz wichtig
dass die menschen einfach entlassen
sender aus hameln an land und ausland
aus
[Musik]
die
vor acht jahren hat carl bertha als
19-jährige das elterliche recycling
business übernommen und gleich einiges
umgekrempelt
ihr konzept weg vom rauen schrotthändler
image zum recycling paradies mit eigener
kinder enkel
ursprünglich wollte karin bärtschi
helikopter piloten werden in der armee
nach der unteroffiziersschule platzte
jedoch der traum so steckte sie ihre
ganze energie ins familienunternehmen
dank mut zur innovation gewann sie
verschiedene unternehmer preise die
medienpräsenz war zweifellos der
türöffner in die politik ende 2016 wurde
barry auf anhieb ins aargauer
kantonsparlament gewählt aufständen und
sind alle bisherigen bezirks in den
rachen und damit nicht rund und formiert
die statik station 8000 serie und denn
als vorschlag an die beklagte wort und
dominierten
[Musik]
sonstige boni politik wird die enge welt
sache schnell umsetzen kann ich
vielleicht auch nicht so schön der
parlaments alltag ist für die
unternehmerin noch immer
gewöhnungsbedürftig dass sie für die svp
politisiert können die grossen rat nicht
alle nachvollziehen
[Musik]
30 gestoßen unternehmerin setzte stiefel
sorgt sie dafür dass die personen zu
betrachten also eigentlich politisiert
weil ich muss die politik ruth als
unternehmerin plant karin bärtschi
großes auf 5500 quadratmetern soll in
spreitenbach ein neuer recyclinghof
entstehen die baueingabe steht bevor
also was breitenbach ich hab's ganz
besonderen gruß und wieder hallo sagen
und das ganze spiel und mit sich zwar in
einer dieser agglomeration spraitbacher
bis jetzt noch gebühren oder beste
werfer würde zu machen
[Musik]
tiptop
8,5 super-saison sicht ein projekt würde
sich ihr wisst liebe ich glaub's nicht
noch mehr blicke klaus google maps ob es
denn wirklich realisierbar ist
aber es ist so viel gold die auf
grundstücken erwerben sagt die
zuständige kommission das kurz gehören
das kommt echt cool in der
bundeshauptstadt besucht karen bärtschi
eintreffen der recyclingbranche
hallo
[Musik]
ja du bist stark
präsident des recycling verbandes vsm r
ist ihr parteikollege toni brunner
die beiden können sich seit längerem
[Gelächter]
toni brunner doch als politikerin
schmackhaft macht ja das klappen wir
schon für sich - das habe ich mir so wie
die politik sei am morgen ortszeit ich
bin politiker nicht mehr die zweite
sondern sind wirklich möchte sie einfach
luft leichter hand und probiert machte
toni brunner die svp schmackhaft weil
sie in den medien bekannt ist bärtschi
war er nur mäßig ambitioniert für die
politik sagt sie sieht er auf die nase
das war möglich wenn sie die svp stark
machte und schweiz erfolgreich wenn sie
dir autor vertreter und darum natürlich
sind mediencenter gern lud porträtieren
wo anno von buschehr hergefallen
ich meine warum hannich sowie braucht
[Gelächter]
und die leute dass du gut unser wunsch
weil ich ja schwierig nur mit der sie
hockt nicht aufs maul
auch wenn es um themen geht bei denen
sie von der svp linie abweicht stichwort
flüchtlings beschäftigung
ja das ist ja letztlich eine möglichkeit
können sie einen bogen ist rockig portal
als wirtschafts migrant oder isra lieb
und leber gefördert was ich eigentlich
grundsatzfrage und darum bin ich der
politischen linien dass ich sagt der
integrationsprozess eher steigen wenn es
wirklich so wichtig dass man weiß wer ab
bliebe ja daran dass sireo portugiesisch
sie sind die chance genutzt hand und so
machten die politiker sind tools die
connection mit dem toni brunner
ich glaube es war für mich vor auf 7
nicht richtig in der mitte partei
politisiert hatte wenn ich zeige ja ich
weg des geringsten widerstands ich habe
man sowohl mit offenheit ich mache ich
so mit den chefs förder und so fuhren
transformierten fällig und deshalb bin
ich wirklich erfahren griff sie
beirren ließ sie sich jedoch nicht trotz
mahnender stimmen sieben uhr morgens in
der aargauer gemeinde leimbach das
elternhaus von karen bärtschi ihr lebt
sie mit eltern und geschwistern
seit sommer ist sie verheiratet mit
ehemann cg die beiden leben noch
getrennt da das gemeinsame eigenheim im
bau ist
heute interessiert ein anderes
bauprojekt bei der familien morgen
sitzung gibt es neuigkeiten aus
breitenbach am recycling unternehmen
sind alle bärtschi geschwister beteiligt
die zwei haben so wie sie sind kann sich
selbst ja also wenn sich so bald nichts
mit rückbau und trägst du dich mal um zu
wenn sonst so und ist zwar cool wenn sie
zwei und fraktionen gibt und hat zwei
millionen stück aber das würde den wert
des geländes jedoch auf anhieb
verdoppeln
zwei hauptstadt diskutieren und
behauptet dass die möglichkeit mit
motivationsgrund
staub tja zuschüsse grundsatzentscheid
richtig machen darin auch die lange
variante 2
und wenn wir das ganze box wochen
eigentlich neu machen also statt 15 pro
woche besucht so manche ist auch die
akkus fordern dass man so viel nachsicht
mutter findet seine expansion genug für
probleme
doch nicht expandieren und danach
als flüchtling kam will giesa im rahmen
eines beschäftigungs programms vor einem
jahr nach hunzenschwil wollte hat er
seinen letzten arbeitstag im unternehmen
von karin berg die zeit als hilfskraft
in hunzenschwil war wegweisend für den
er hat nun eine aufenthaltsbewilligung
und es wartet auf ihn eine neue aufgabe
in einem anderen betrieb
das heißt gewählt
das fernsehfilme und sie sind alle mit
hilfe dieses gefährlichsten lied der
deutschen
[Musik]
also wer noch ganz wenig bei der
planzahl hautfarbe einen krieg zum
schluss also nehmen wir doch sie mit
dieser witzigen die zwei jahre nach der
besten seit gestern herrscht gewissheit
dem hause bärtschi in spreitenbach darf
gebaut werden
der spatenstich für den dritten
recyclinghof steht bevor
und doch eher unerwartet entscheid das
modul unbefristet die lösung könnte und
es ist besser dass minister trend hatte
[Gelächter]
ich merke kohl jan o
[Musik]
er wurde
natürlich dürfen sie nicht fehlt
um 6,8 auf der links
[Musik]
na dann
und ist gott zuständig
[Musik]
der erfolg scheint programm zu sein im
leben von karin bärtschi möglich sei
dies alles nur dank glücklicher fügung
so ihre überzeugung seit ihrer kindheit
ist sie mitglied einer freikirche
ich glaube sowieso sehr stark bei fluss
und ich glaube ich würde für die
entscheidungen am andere strafen wenn
ich jetzt das unabhängig von religion
und glaube müsste machen wenn man
einfach auch wirtschaftliche jahr satz
nach deiner wirke und ja so spielt
natürlich die sozialkomponente spielte
immer nach limit in bezug auf die
flüchtlingsfrage integriere chancen
bieten und erhöht ganz klar also in der
stadt schenken kann fisch lernen in
fischen und das kommt aber sie mit sack
pack und siemens sauber machen aber ohne
rechtlichen grund würde ich ganz sicher
kraus ersuchen die beschäftigen der
letzte schauplatz unseres films bringt
licht in karin bärtschis denken und
handeln
sie liebt nach christlichen werten die
ihre soziale seite aber auch ihre
konservative haltung erklären
ein thema habe sie ganz entscheidend
dazu bewogen der svp beizutreten
[Musik]
also wenn wir jetzt wieder drews gesehen
also alexander sturm klavier
aber dann macht es auch was genau hinter
und frau sind wurde drauf
gut aussah machte nochmals vorspiel
[Musik]
dauer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hj